troisième finale de la coupe d'hiver au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
la compétition au groupe et cette année
8 franciliens de la catégorie minime aux
élites événement est en pleine expansion
elle est passé de 90 à plus de 130
participants depuis sa création
ça fait partie des objectifs de beaucoup
de coureurs et de beaucoup de pistard et
cette coupe d'hiver fait partie de nous
d'une très bonne préparation et pour
certains ils vont attaquer les épreuves
sur route notamment les coureurs
d'endurance pour attaquer les épreuves
sur route dans un mois et donc c'est une
excellente préparation à la piste parmi
ces coureurs présents ont retrouvé 24
féminine sur la piste une première pour
l'événement marine cloarec du club de
plus tôt n'a pas hésité à participer à
ce rendez vous au vélodrome nationale
pour promouvoir le cyclisme sur piste
féminin vous permet de vous mettre en
avant et de voir que le cyclisme féminin
attend 6 à faire de la piste et que
voilà on est on a quand même un niveau
et que on a notre place aussi plus dans
le cyclisme sorti une nouvelle édition
devrait être organisée l'année prochaine
des manches supplémentaires pourraient
être ajoutés objectif pérenniser
l'événement dans le temps